alors je crois que vous avez été vous
avez une invitation pour le trail baba
noël directement à domicile
notre père noël au chocolat a frappé
fort regardez
[Musique]
michel j'avais une pour toi de la part
des séries d'amour
merci
[Musique]
6 à l'hommage aux francas le ménage
vous voyez cette boîte devant des
caméras venant tpp alors vous mettez
mais alors un doigt dans le cul mes
propos voilà donc où vrai je vais
regarder de loin mais non mais les mecs
arrêtez vous redoublez les méga l'ouvrir
passé
[Musique]
c'est que c'est encore
je vais petit
[Musique]
oh
c'est mauvais
[Musique]
mais
oui bonjour madame j'ai un coulis à vous
livrez vous êtes chez vous d'accord
bombe a sonné merci
[Musique]
sinon
non mais c'est quoi
[Musique]
bon bah tiens c'est parfait
c'est vraiment vouziers m'avoir tiens
tiens tu as à tarbes hanouna tu m'auras
pas cette fois à lille
c
m